this is the most disturbing video
not that I've ever seen but it's up
there
a Dutch TV show is promoting
transgenderism and specifically
transgenderism to kids by taking a group
of little kids specifically minors and
then bringing in a bunch of transgender
identifying confused people and having
them strip naked and having the kids
look at their bodies
Simply Naked adults get undressed these
kids 10 to 12 years old get the
opportunity to ask them questions about
their naked body and today our guests
are transgenders I couldn't believe this
was real at first
yes not feeling can simply be a feeling
but you can also do something about it
for example I had surgery
you can also be transgender and not
undergo any surgeries
as you can see there's something in my
Underpants but I still have a vulva I
don't feel comfortable with that body
part therefore I'm wearing my underwear
with a packer I think that means like a
cucumber or something vaginoplasty what
does that mean
that you surgically change the male sex
organs the female sex organ says this
dude with implants and here's a girl
who's 10 years old later you realize
it's actually pretty normal
it's actually really normal says this 10
year old boy well it's not just male and
female there's an entire
spectrum of genders besides male and
female says this pervert host how did
you feel after you had surgery
do you know the word euphoric no she
tells the kid euphoric means extremely
happy but put a pause there
this to me is the most disturbing part
of the video the whole thing's
disturbing these kids are so little
these people are so naked they're
talking about sex
reminds me of that Meme from Oren
McIntyre which I was somewhat skeptical
of but
every day it seems truer and truer which
is it's a meme of a guy pointing to a
sign and says it's not that complicated
they just want to ditto kids
these are adult people stripping naked
talking about sex and sexual Euphoria to
10 year old kids boys and girls on TV
they're not hiding this this is not in
some CD alley they're putting it all out
there they're not hiding the gay porn
for the little kids they're putting it
right there in the elementary school
library they're campaigning on it
and then this woman says
do you know the word Euphoria little
kids say no I don't know what Euphoria
is says I woke up and I knew my breasts
were gone that I looked like I had
always wanted it to look and I was
euphoric I was ecstatic I felt the best
and happiest I could ever feel do you
want to feel that way kids that's
obviously the implication
kids are always chasing some kind of
high some kind of short-term feeling of
of excitement that's why they run and
eat the candy bars and eat too many
cookies in the cookie jar and go crazy
they're kids they don't have control
over their over their rational will
and this
woman I get is a woman I think or a man
I don't know says oh I yeah I guess it's
a woman because she had her breasts
removed
she says oh yeah it's so euphoric
just planting that seed let me know if
you want to chop them off keep going
okay
finally match the way that I feel inside
and that made me feel ecstatic yeah so
it feels a bit like flying yes you
simply feel intense happiness to little
kids obviously we've blurred and
censored this whole clip
the original Ain't blurred okay and so
people are gonna watch this they say wow
that's really crazy the reason I bring
it up at all is because
this is exactly what the libs are doing
here in the United States there's no
difference
the Dutch are a little more Brazen about
these things they sometimes seem a
little more avant-garde
and when they go live they go all the
way lib when they introduce assisted
suicide for instance
it's not just a handful of people who
are in extreme pain at the very end of
their lives very quickly they start just
murdering people they hold grannies down
and kill them against their will they
start killing young people they start
pushing it on children
but we're doing the same thing here
there is a very good chance that if your
kids are in elementary school right now
they will have access to a book in their
Library called genderqueer by Maya
kababi which is just a book version of
this show it's just a book with very
graphic weird sex in it that's available
in many many elementary schools around
the country
when the
Biden Administration starts pushing
quote-unquote gender affirming care onto
kids of all all ages and they reiterated
their support for that last week they're
doing the same thing that these guys are
doing when they push sex education at
younger and younger ages when they push
back against Ron desantis's Bill in
Florida that says you can't do this kind
of stuff until the kids enter fourth
grade
you can only kindergarten to third grade
you're not allowed to push this stuff
and then the libs go apoplectic over it
protect trans kids protect trans kids by
allowing us to strip down naked in front
of them and tell them that you a fork to
chop their genitals off
we in America are doing the same well
now we you and I are not doing it but
the Liberals are doing the very same
thing here in America it's like it's
like the new flag of our country in fact
Richard Levine
good old dick Levine who now goes by
Rachel
he is the assistant Secretary of Health
at the Department of Health and Human
Services he thinks that he is
a woman
he just bragged about the new flag
flying over HHS happy transgender day of
visibility I am Admiral Rachel Levine
the assistant secretary for health at
the Department of Health and Human
Services for the second year in a row
the transgender flag is flying above our
department in Washington DC and this is
an affirmation of the administration's
support for the transgender community
and Across the Nation as well as our
support for evidence-based gender
affirming care
produced by the U.S Department of Health
and Human Services
produced by HHS this is the flag of the
liberal Empire I've pointed this out for
a long time there are two flags that
purport to represent America there's the
old Stars and Stripes the Star-Spangled
Banner that's the flag of the
traditional American Nation
then there's the rainbow flag and the
pride progress flag and the trans flag
they're all just variations on a theme
and the way that we have the Betsy Ross
flag and the Gadsden flag and the Grand
Union Flag those were all early American
national flags
so too we have these early American
Imperial Flags
those rainbow flags are the flags of our
Empire of the liberal Empire
and they're specifically geared to be
liberal Imperial Flags because they
don't respect any borders they're not
just about America they're coming from
America but they're supposed to apply
everywhere in the world this is why when
the Liberals run the government when the
Biden Administration runs the government
they go into the Vatican and they hoist
a rainbow flag this is obviously
contrary to Christian teaching it's
contrary to Jewish teaching and Muslim
teaching and
most normal teaching throughout all of
human history in all sorts of cultural
and religious systems
but they go and they specifically hoist
that flag because that that is a
statement that our beliefs on weird
sexual practices and chopping off
genitals and pretending to be the
opposite sex and are are cultish views
on this they apply to everybody it's not
just for us it's for everybody we've got
to stay in Afghanistan to project LGBT
LMNOP rights we have to
people and people have a fundamental
right to chop off their genitals and we
need to commit another 20 years and who
knows
how much in the way of treasure and the
efforts and potentially lives of our
service members to defend LGBT LMNOP
rights in Kandahar right
that's what they do I promise you if you
pulled 100 Libs
and you said which flag do you identify
more with the rainbow flag or the Stars
and Stripes
a significant portion probably the
majority would say the rainbow flag
that's the flag of the liberal Empire
it's music Monday Baby the rest of the
show continues now you don't want to
miss it become a member use code Noel
scanner wlas a checkout for two months
free on all annual plans
[Music]
oh